jake paul the youtube sensation made
over 40 million dollars last year
according to forbes that's right jake
paul is now the highest earning athlete
under the age of 25. now the guy they
call the problem child he's not only a
problem in the ring he obviously is
making a problem with this bank account
jake paul is doing it the right way too
not only would he get paid millions of
dollars for fighting inside of a boxing
ring but he also made money on youtube
he made money owning the product motion
companies everything this guy touches is
turned into gold now jake paul obviously
made more money than a lot of people in
the world but he also made more money
than most of the top athletes that you
know he made more money than canelo
alvarez many think is the best boxer in
the world right now he made just as much
as phil mickelson and also he made more
money than the number one tennis star in
the world jake paul is not only the
highest earning athlete under the age of
25. jake paul out earned many of the
same people and other sports that you
look up to and respect now that what's
interesting to me is jake paul's not
just getting paid to fight jake paul's
winning as well he's 5-0 he's knocked
out every single fighter that he's ever
fought and ultimately jake paul is
making noise on the internet but that
noise is backed up by substance and so
if jake paul right now is making 40
million dollars a year if he continues
on this path if he continues to invest
in his venture capital fund he continues
to build businesses and he continues to
knock out opponents in the ring jake
paul is going to become a billionaire
and there's almost no doubt in my mind
one of the things that helps him is that
jake paul also doesn't pay taxes on the
money he makes he lives in puerto rico
where there's very low to almost no
taxation on the island and so jake paul
obviously known for being a disney star
in a youtube sensation but now jake paul
is morphed into an entrepreneur and an
investor and he's doing it at a
world-class level but while he's being a
world-class operator he's also talking
[ __ ] on the internet and knocking people
out in the ring kudos to jake paul
something tells me this kid's just
getting started